[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en 2015 dans le cadre de mes études de
médecine
je pars en mission humanitaire au népal
après deux tragiques au séisme je
travaille dans une zone assez reculée
loin de la capitale dans les montagnes
et je gère un dépôt de produits
pharmaceutiques
un jour en faisant mon inventaire de
médicaments je m'aperçois que certains
médicaments sont contrefaits
naturellement je suis choqué et je dois
agir
je n'arrive pas à concevoir que des
populations soient exposés à la
dangerosité de ces médicaments
spontanément je me dis que l'idée la
plus pertinente seraient des ti côté
chaque boîte de médicament
lorsque je suis vraiment certain de la
qualité de ce médicament pour cela
j'appelle le laboratoire pharmaceutique
qui produit le médicament que j'ai entre
les mains et je lui demande s'il a bel
et bien produit ce médicament avec ce
numéro de lot donc ça c'est un processus
malheureusement qui est très chronophage
ça prend du temps d'appeler le
laboratoire pharmaceutique et lui
demander à tu produis ce lot de
médicaments
c'est très coûteux en et au népal et en
plus de ça il ya des répliques sismiques
donc c'est très compliqué de pouvoir
toujours contacter laboratoire et pire
le contrefacteur c'est à dire le
laboratoire clandestin qui est capable
de produire des faux médicaments il peut
très bien écrire le même numéro de lot
puisque vous avez des dizaines de
milliers de médicaments qui ont ce même
numéro 2 l'année suivante je pars en
afrique je fais le même constat les
médicaments falsifiés sont aussi très
présents j'ai la chance de me déplacer
dans la majorité des pays de l'afrique
francophone et je constate à chaque fois
que dont on a des marchés de rue on a
des vendeurs de faux médicaments et je
me souviendrai toujours de ce patient
chez qui m'avait jour très gentiment
hébergé qui malheureusement est condamné
à passer le reste de ses jours
trois fois par semaine il est obligé
d'aller à l'hôpital pour des séances de
dialyse à cause de la consommation d'un
antibiotique falsifiés il est devenu
insuffisant rénal le médicaments de la
rue
je pense que vous voyez ce que c'est non
bon bien sûr en afrique subsaharienne
malheureusement nous connaissons tous
cette triste réalité dans la rue en
afrique subsaharienne
on trouve des faux médicaments alors ces
faux médicaments fréquemment ils ont des
principes actifs qui ne correspondent
pas à ce qui est prévu normalement
par exemple on va avoir des principes
actifs surdosé sous dosés voire absence
de principes actifs même des molécules
différentes et pire on a déjà trouvé de
la mort aux rats dans certains
médicaments les excipients sont toxiques
dans les faux médicaments
j'ouvre une parenthèse très rapidement
le mois dernier la gendarmerie nationale
de côte d'ivoire a trouvé dans une villa
à cocody de son tonnes de faux
médicaments
c est le mois dernier donc pour la
postérité nous sommes aujourd'hui en
décembre 2010 9 200 tonnes ce n'est pas
d'ailleurs un épiphénomène est dans la
rue on trouve quelque chose de beaucoup
plus pernicieux on trouve des vrais
médicaments mais attention ces
médicaments sont détournés du circuit
légal et le vrai problème c'est qu'ils
sont stockés dans des conditions
désastreuses qui vont vraiment détérioré
les qualités du médicament je ne vous
l'apprends pas en afrique subsaharienne
les taux d'humidité et les températures
sont toujours très élevés donc
impossible de conserver dans la rue en
médicaments on ne conserve bien ces
médicaments que dans les pharmacies
le ms a décidé de qualifier tous les
médicaments de la rue de médicaments de
qualité inférieure et falsifiés donc
pour plus de simplicité je parlerai de
médicaments falsifiés pendant mon
intervention un million de morts chaque
année à cause de ces médicaments
d'accord cela peut paraître surréaliste
mais en afrique subsaharienne vous avez
à peu près 50% de la population qui
achète son médicament dans la rue c'est
très problématique
comprenez que les médicaments falsifiés
c'est un véritable fléau c'est un drame
sanitaire
un drame économique mais surtout c'est
un drame méconnu tant par la presse que
par l'opinion publique que par les
décideurs politiques les médicaments
falsifiés c'est un double crime un crime
contre la santé est un crime social
contre les plus pauvres et le pire c'est
qu'il est en fait une sorte de comment
dirais-je
les gens ne réalisent pas et il ya une
sorte d'indifférence à cet état de fait
et je trouve que c'est vraiment anormal
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
de quelque chose qui permet activement
de lutter contre ce problème je vous
parlais de la sérialisation des
médicaments voilà deux boîtes de
médicaments regardons dans un premier
temps la première boîte de médicaments
celles qui se trouvent sur la gauche de
votre écran vous voyez ce médicament on
retrouve plusieurs informations
on retrouve la date de fabrication on
retrouve la date d'expiration et on
trouve un numéro de lot vous avez
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de boîtes
qui ont ces mêmes informations
si un médicament de ce lot est
défectueux le laboratoire peut demander
le retrait de ce lot c'est un processus
qui est très efficace mais par contre
avec ces informations ne peut pas
s'assurer de l'authenticité de ce
médicament
maintenant regardant l'autre médicament
celui qui se trouve sur la droite de
votre écran
je ne vais pas vous faire jouer au jeu
des différences vous avez probablement
remarqué qu'il y avait un élément
supplémentaire c'est un petit qu'à ce
petit carré ça s'appelle un data matrix
un data matrix c'est un code à barres
universel dans lequel on va mettre une
information supplémentaire là dedans en
fait il ya un numéro de série unique ce
qui est très intéressant c'est que
chaque boîte de la sorte et tuniques ce
médicament est unique parce que je
retrouve un numéro 2 dans on parle de la
sérialisation des médicaments à l'unité
et vous avez peut-être fait le
rapprochement avec ce que je faisais moi
manuellement au népal getti côté les
boîtes en mettant des numéros uniques
c'était une façon très artisanale en
fait de reproduire la sérialisation en
fait à mes yeux c'est une réalité c'est
une véritable aberration
pourquoi les laboratoires ne se
réalisent pas toujours leurs médicaments
sachant que aujourd'hui en europe tous
les médicaments sont sérialisé résultats
n'importe quel pharmaciens dans une
officine peut s'assurer de
l'authenticité de l'authenticité de son
médicament
en afrique ce n'est pas le cas à mes
yeux c'est une profonde injustice
pourquoi les médicaments en afrique ne
sont pas autant sécurisés que les
médicaments en europe pourquoi la
traçabilité des médicaments en afrique
est elle aussi opaque
bon maintenant que je vous ai assommer
avec
avec un discours assez académique je
vais vous parler de la naissance de mass
start up en 2017 lorsque j'étais
étudiant en médecine en santé publique
je vais un double cursus l'université de
bordeaux a organisé un événement ou des
développeurs informatiques rencontrer
des professionnels de santé
alors moi j'étais assez fasciné par
l'univers des développeurs informatiques
et l'objectif c'était de mettre en place
des prototypes des solutions pour
répondre à des problèmes de santé
publique finalement nous avons remporté
le premier prix de la région de
l'aquitaine que je tiens sincèrement à
remercier puisqu'il nous soutiennent
activement depuis le début du projet et
lors de la remise des prix je vais
inviter un ami à moi de ma promotion de
santé publique était béninois et il
avait déclaré en utilisant notre petit
prototype mon médicament je détecte si
les vrais ou faux médicaments détecte
meditec tu vois là le projet meditec
tenais un peu grâce à cet étudiant est
très rapidement j'en ai parlé un de mes
amis d'enfance romain renard qui lui est
diplômé de sciences po paris et qui lui
aussi est très sensible aux enjeux de
santé publique en particulier de santé
internationales et ensemble on a décidé
de co fondé mais détecte mais par contre
on avait vraiment cette forte volonté de
développer une solution scalable est une
solution vraiment efficace pas comme au
népal il nous fallait une solution
simple rapide efficace et moins coûteuse
et là on décide en fait d'utiliser une
nouvelle technologie
la technologie blu chain alors les blocs
shane c'est une technologie qui va
permettre de stocker et de transmettre
de l'information de façon sécurisée
transparente et décentralisé c'est à
dire sans organe central de contrôle
imaginez un livre géant lorsqu'un
laboratoire pharmaceutique va produire
un médicament il va inscrire dans ce
livre le numéro qu'il a apposée sur son
médicament
lorsqu un pharmacien va réceptionner le
médicament il va chercher dans le livret
va tourner les pages si le numéro existe
si tel est le cas il s'assure que sa
boîte et authentique et à son tour il va
écrire le lieu et l'heure quand il a
réceptionné ce médicament ça empêche que
ce médicament soit copié puisque on sait
dans le livre que son médicament a déjà
été réceptionné par
mais on ne peut pas effacer ce qui est
dans le livre ce qui est très
intéressant dans ce système c'est qu'il
est transparent
tout le monde peut lire le livre il est
sécurisé on ne peut pas effacer des
parties du livre et il est décentralisée
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas un auteur
qui va rédiger le livre non il va ya
voir en fait directement tous les
laboratoires qui vont pouvoir écrire
dans ce délire donc c'est une solution
qui est vraiment très efficace
en réalité ce n'est pas un livre qui
relie des pages les pages ce sont des
blocs dans lesquels nous mettons des
informations et ce n'est pas un livre
qui relie des blogs c'est une chaîne
voilà pourquoi ça s'appelle la bloquer
et lorsque j'ai compris avec romain
vraiment la pertinence d'utiliser cette
technologie qu'elle peut vraiment
révolutionné la traçabilité des
médicaments en particulier en afrique
j'étais tiraillé entre l'envié de
poursuivre mes études de médecine pour
travailler dans un bloc opératoire plus
tard et potentiellement sauver une vie
et l'envié de suspendre mes études et
retourner sur le terrain
et finalement c'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai suspendu mes études et je suis
reparti en 2018 en ou 2018 faire une
étude de faisabilité à ouagadougou au
burkina faso avec des pharmaciens
d'officine l'objectif était simple
c'était démontré que la solution que
qu'on avait réalisé elle pouvait
vraiment marcher elle pouvait impacter
la vie des gens j'étais très confiant je
me disais une autre application voilà
elle allait bouleverser les choses
non pas du tout ce fut un échec mais
l'échec quand même très constructif on
avait déjà négliger un acteur clé de la
chaîne de distribution du médicament en
s'intéressant en particulier aux
laboratoires et aux pharmaciens
mais il fallait avant tout s'intéresser
aux patients une réalité c'est que à
ouagadougou je remarquais que tous les
citoyens avaient un smartphone et qu'on
pouvait vraiment responsabiliser le
patient grâce à son smartphone donc on a
commencé à créer des groupes de travail
avec les patients et pour le temps qu'il
nous accordait en fait on leur donnait
de l'accès internet est en fait il après
c'est vraiment le fait de recevoir de
l'accès internet lorsqu'on les sollicite
et et on s'est dit mais en fait on
devrait toujours offrir de l'accès
internet aux gens qui vont pharmacie qui
ne vont pas acheter leurs médicaments
dans la rue et ça on l'a conservé encore
aujourd'hui sur notre application
lorsque vous allez dans une pharmacie
vous gagnez de l'accès internet si vous
allez dans la rue vous ne gagnez rien
et les passants il nous disait une autre
rona qui quand même très intéressante
c'est qu'ils ont envie d'avoir sur leur
smartphone des informations sur leur
traitement
on peut envoyer des messages très simple
et des messages très clairs je vous
racontais une très triste anecdote un de
mes enfants c'était le frère de la
personne qui m'a hébergée à ouagadougou
un soir on était à table il avait besoin
de se soigner et il a mis dans sa boule
d'attaquer un suppositoire
c'était assez difficile pour moi de voir
justement le que les patients voient là
ne maîtrisent pas forcément l'adhérence
thérapeutique des choses très simples
voilà ça peut par contre être assez
compliqué revenant de nouveau à mon
histoire
nous sommes fin 2018 l'étude de
faisabilité est terminée et avec romain
nous avons vraiment envie de passer à
une échelle beaucoup plus importantes on
veut maintenant proposer une autre
solution à l'échelle d'un pays
notre volonté c'est montrer que notre
solution est efficace
donc on décide de proposer une autre
solution à la côte d'ivoire
pourquoi la côte d'ivoire c'est le pays
le plus important d'afrique francophone
et en afrique de l'ouest et notre
volonté elle était assez simple en
réalité c'était assurer la traçabilité
du médicament le plus utilisé ce
médicament
il est produit par un laboratoire qui
s'appelle luxair qui se trouvent en
région nouvelle aquitaine la région où
j'ai grandi et le site de production se
trouve à seulement une heure de chez moi
donc je me suis rendu j'ai rencontré les
équipes et j'ai été agréablement surpris
de voir que le laboratoires upsa est
engagé dans la lutte contre le
médicament de la rue et qu'ils cherchent
à renforcer et à utiliser des
innovations des technologies nouvelles
pour le bien de leurs patients pour
lutter encore contre le médicament de la
rue en mai 2010 neuf nous officialisons
notre collaboration
honnêtement j'étais assez inquiet parce
qu'on n'avait pas encore un seul
pharmaciens partenaires en côte d'ivoire
et la question c'était mais comment
allait-il réagir est-ce qu'ils allaient
adopter notre application est là cette
fois c'est un franc succès on a vraiment
su montrer à l'ensemble des pharmaciens
qu'on avait un outil digital et aussi
aux pharmaciens qui elle était vraiment
qu'il a vraiment bouleverser les choses
et qu'on est les vamps loire disrupt et
la situation est ce qu'elle est très
intéressant c'est que à tel point
c'était
un franc succès l'ordre national des
pharmaciens et le ministère de la santé
ont décidé de communiquer massivement
elles sont beaucoup plus larges afin que
notre solution soit adopté par tout le
monde on a vraiment démontré à ce moment
là que la sérialisation des médicaments
a toute sa place ici en côte d'ivoire et
dans toute la sous région
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que nous avons
l'ensemble des pharmaciens de côté d'or
qui aura bientôt et qui fera bientôt qui
revient tous rejoint le réseau meditec
tessa c'est une très bonne nouvelle
la semaine dernière c'était vraiment il
ya deux semaines je me trouvais à abobo
avec un pharmacien jeu le former à
l'usagé de notre application et dès le
début de la formation il m'a dit oui
meditec je connais c'est pour mes
détecter si son médicament est vrai ou
faux là j'ai appris que le le verbe de
méditer existe elle j'en suis tombé des
nues et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que les pharmaciens ils ont
vraiment besoin d'avoir accès aux
nouvelles technologies
et ça ça passe aussi par une étroite
collaboration avec les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
nous chez mais des textes dans notre
entreprise on a vraiment envie de
contribuer à développer le monde de
demain
ensemble on peut vraiment lutter contre
ce fléau
je vous invite vraiment à nous suivre
sur les réseaux sociaux né à partager
nos actions la semaine dernière j'étais
à treichville dans une pharmacie et une
jeune maman est arrivée au comptoir de
la pharmacie et a demandé au pharmacien
pourquoi son médicament ne fonctionnait
pas sur son nourrisson fonctionné j'ai
pas trop aimé ce terme est en réalité il
s'agissait d'une grossière contrefaçons
ce qui m'a vraiment bouleversée
je pense vraiment qu'avec meditec ce
genre de situation ne se reproduira pas
je suis persuadé que demain nous allons
éradiquer le médicaments de la rue
nous ne prendrons plus de risques en
consommant un médicament en afrique
subsaharienne et nous allons vraiment
digitaliser et révolutionner la relation
aux médicaments telle est ma conviction
[Applaudissements]